welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the slow
march of eminent decay of our mortal
forms
and who's the real daddy warbucks of the
comic world
i just realized his last name is
warbucks like does daddy warbucks make
all of his money from war
is he a woman i'm gonna assume so i
would assume war is a very profitable uh
thing i hear
that's really dark for little orphan
annie i'm getting ahead of myself i'm
off screen producer brandon and i'm here
with
mt say hello to the people greetings
people i hope you all are doing well i
missed you
it's been a while since i've seen you
even though it's only been a couple of
days but
hello the people missed you too empty
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
all right let's hop into the big
question this week the falcon and winter
soldier has introduced some new super
soldiers onto the mcu chess board
we got the mysterious organization the
flag smashers we've finally been
introduced to isaiah bradley an american
super soldier
bucky fought as the winter soldier back
in 1951
and who was then imprisoned and kept
secret from the public terrible stuff
but all of these super soldiers really
bring up one of our favorite ontological
questions
how does aging work differently for
super soldiers
that is a fantastic question brandon i'm
glad you asked it
um well before we talk about that we got
to talk about
us because there's more humans on the
world than super soldiers i don't know
what people have told you but
that is the case
aging in humans is natural and has many
effects on the body and we do it every
day
it's against our will it's literally the
worst don't do it if you can just aging
i hate aging
my bones hurt every day um ever since i
turned 25
just don't do it at a microscopic level
our cells die off and new cells replace
them
as we age but at some point the new
cells stop coming because our genes are
programmed
to limit the number of times a cell can
divide and make new cells
as a result of this most bodily
functions peak before age 30 and then
the slow decline begins i'm 29 so i'm
feeling that slow decline
right now i wish i was 29 mt i wish i
was still 29 that would be great
29 is uh it's pretty good but uh i'm
starting to feel it brandon start to
feel stay there
apparently 30 is when it all starts to
go downhill stay at 29 for as long as
you can
stay as long as you can for the love of
god
cherish it the eyes and ears are usually
the first things to change
but a lot of other effects of aging can
be seen throughout the body i mean
bones become less dense joints begin to
break down as the cartilage weakens
muscles become less strong our skin
becomes thinner
and less elastic the nerve cells in our
brain decrease
and even our sense of smell and taste
gets weaker which i'm not looking
forward to
i mean at that point it's just like how
do i just how do i survive without the
sense of smell and taste brandon how do
i tell if the cheese has gone bad if i
can't smell it exactly you're just gonna
have to just
just pray just eat the cheese anyway
just pray
oh cheese gods please give me unmoldy
cheese this day
cheese gods please don't don't hurt me
cheese guts delicious cheese gods
oh the lactose gods have forsaken me oh
me too i am very lactose intolerant
brandon oh no
i've been tossed out of the kingdom of
lactose oh man
the lactose gang uh i envy you
i envy all of you guys that can uh eat
lactose i am not part of lactose gang
there are a lot more awful terrifying
depressing things that can happen to our
frail human bodies as we age
but i just wanted to hit the highlights
and give you a concise idea
about the process of aging i appreciate
you keeping it peppy
no problem it's what i do it's just you
know just
gotta keep it positive light we're all
dying every day you know bro
it's the little things brandon just
creeping towards the grave my friend
just creeping towards the grave
but our super soldier friends do not
have to worry about this problem which
is
great steve i'm glad you can you don't
have to worry about that think about
that
aging for them is completely different
there are different versions of the
super soldier serum out there
but it seems like every version has the
effect of enhancing the metabolic
cellular and chemical processes of the
body and this increases strength
stamina and healing abilities while
building up greater resistances to
fatigue
and exhaustion more importantly they
appear to age
much slower than you and me looking
fresh in their old age
and even even i see a bradley he's been
looking he's still looking pretty good
for his ears
and uh you know what they say brandon
black don't crack so is that what they
say
it's what they say every day it is what
they say
it's all it's about the first words my
mother told me he's like listen young
baby
black don't crack you'll be looking like
this for
your 85. the first words my mother told
me were stay out of the moldy cheese
don't eat the moldy cheese brandon trust
your sense of smell and taste
now it's important to keep in mind that
steve rogers is the only super soldier
that we
know of that has received the original
dr erc sign formula with the ever
important
vita rays every other super soldier has
been the result of an attempt to
recreate that formula
with varying degrees of success yeah
steve got that
uncut irks kind of like this is the real
juice this is the real mama jama he's
like don't worry steve i'm going to make
so much of this stuff we're going to
have home armies full of erskine's
formula it's going to be great
man like it's that original original
recipe kfc
that steve gots in his veins man oh
that's the good stuff
finger looking good delicious now we'll
go through the super soldiers that we do
know of and see if we can determine
their aging process starting with
captain america born on july 4th
1918. what a coincidence right what a
coincidence for old captain america
right i feel like their parents had to
play that's like
i think it's like retconning by the us
government like they probably went in
and changed his like birthday
to make it july 4th i wouldn't be
surprised like you got to look more
patriotic and there's nothing patriotic
about
august 2nd sorry all you august 2nd
i'm so sorry i'd be true patriotic
anyway so he was born on july 4th 1918
and he gets the serum
in 1943 and in 1945 he crashes into the
arctic ice
and is frozen at age 27 which is you
know he's done a lot more at 27 than
i've ever done
so that's still pretty good and and then
he's thought out in 2011
66 years later but he's actually 27
since he was frozen that entire time
yeah because this is like going to be
important because
right because when you're frozen in the
ice you're not aging i guess because his
metabolism is so slow
he's like barely moving yeah so like
your biological age is still
27 even though like on paper he's 66 but
he's
27. yeah he looks great when he comes
out oh yeah he looks fantastic
um i haven't been frozen i uh i look
like i'm 56.
i've been very cold before never frozen
i mean i live in new england so we're
just perpetually frozen i guess
you're like 106 right you look great
and then by the end of the final battle
with thanos an endgame in 2023 he should
be
around like 39 years old and then
he goes through the quantum tunnel to
replace the infinity stones but decides
to
live out in a branch reality with peggy
carter the love of his life
i mean she's she's a very strong
powerful but also coincidentally very
beautiful
british woman yeah and uh i would
totally leave all my friends and family
uh for peggy carter honestly yeah i mean
i would risk the time space continuum to
live out of life with peggy carter don't
tell my wife
right scott i wouldn't even i wouldn't
even text my mom i'd just be like hey
i'm just gone i'm sleeping new phone who
dis sorry i'm in a new reality dog
leave me alone mom everybody knows that
my mom is the only number i have in my
phone
so that's that's really that's like a
you live life like an assassin just one
number on the phone
yes i have a separate from just for my
mom um i don't know what i'm saying
anyway
we can assume that he went back to 1945
around the time he disappeared into the
ice
so when we see him again in end game as
old cap he should be around
170 and he definitely looks and sounds
older
but he's still pretty spry for 117 years
old i gotta say
most people would be mega dead at 117. i
i know that uh i'm probably not gonna
get past 65
because uh no you can't say that mt like
i'm i'm babe ruth of my age i keep
calling it at 120. like i'm living to
one
shoot 120. well i don't spend my life
like i'm gonna make it to 120 but i just
keep calling my shot you know what i
mean you can't put out there that you're
gonna only go
to 65. bro you're gonna make it to 170
bro i can see it right now
one seven zero what am i gonna do with
170
uh i'll be like at 170 are all gonna
look like that shriveled fish from the
spongebob the old ladyfish
from the chocolates episode i remember
when they first
invented chocolate sweet sweet chocolate
i always hated it get off my virtual
lawn
so he comes back he lives out the whole
reality with peggy carter so now he's
117 when he gives
sam the shield right yes he's doing it
he gives sam the shield at 117 but
really he's about
183 because he did spend 66 of those
years on
ice but with a very slow metabolism yeah
his his thought out age is 117. he's 183
on paper 117 thought out
okay yes it's 117 is what he puts on his
uh tinder profile
so uh
but that's steve rogers but next up is
cap's best friend forever
bucky barnes aka the winter soldier now
bucky was born on march 10
1917 and enlisted in the army in 1943
but was captured and given super soldier
serum in that same year i believe and in
1945
but he goes missing during the train
mission and is reclaimed by hydra
and this is where the on and off again
freezing starts
so you're saying he he lists in the
military right
yeah and then he gets he gets captured
in that first year that's a real bummer
he's a people zola zola is like doing
all these things to all these prisoners
and that he gives
he winds up giving some knockoff of the
erskine formula to bucky
yes and then steve comes and liberates
them all
puts together the howling commandos
right and then like during the train
robbery
bucky falls off the train
hi bucky because he has this like serum
in his body already he's able to live
through this scenario right zola finds
him again
and then they give him the arm right
exactly you nailed it brandon
thank you freaking nailed it you it's
almost like you wrote the script
don't tell the people at home that don't
you didn't hear that from me
that is exactly right now we do know
that bucky fought isaiah bradley during
the korean war in 1951
and he is involved with the
assassination of john f kennedy
in 1963 um which is you know highly
unfortunate but
you know highly unfortunate if you if
you're mind controlled
it's fine it's not his fault he's
totally noticed
he's a mind-controlled robot but then in
1991 tony stark's parents
um were murdered by bucky and bucky
would then go on to train some super
soldiers
in that 90s period and then some time
after that
he kills yuri's son as we see in episode
one of falcon in the winter soldier
which is very sad
um i'm sure he feels very bad about that
and then later on he assassinates a
target being protected by black widow
in 2009 oh that's right he like shoots
through her right that's how she
describes it and then she's like bye bye
bikini
yeah she's real chipper about it and i'm
sure she looks fine
in the bikini oh yeah i mean it's
scarlett johansson i mean
i mean i'm me come on come on and then
he comes back in 2014 during the events
of captain america the winter soldier
and he goes on the run makes some amends
after that and then he gets his arm
fried by tony stark in captain america
civil war
and then the aforementioned parent death
comes back to haunt him
oh yes i mean if you kill someone's
parents you can't just feel like you got
away with it because you probably
remember though
he remembers all of that he remembers
every person he killed and that's very
sweet but also
kind of torturous and i'm so sorry he's
very torturous he's making his immense
he's making his immense yeah he's got
his list he's
he's checking it twice he's gonna find
out if he's been naughty or nice
mostly naughty mostly naughty
and then he gets frozen in wakanda in
2016.
we don't know how long he's been frozen
for but we know that he was frozen in
2016.
and then he fights in the battle of
wakanda in 2018
and then gets blipped and then comes
back in 2023
where he's going on adventures with his
best black friend
sam wilson it's always going to have a
best black friend brandon would
i i mean do you have any positions open
because
i'm always accepting applications i'm
just saying
so now it is six months after the blip
so like 20 23
20 24ish and bucky said in episode one
of falcon and the winter soldier that he
is 106 years old now he still looks
pretty damn young but he did spend some
of that time
frozen and he had hydra constantly
monitoring him medically
though their methods aren't always about
putting patient care and comfort first
but
they did a somewhat good job he still
looks pretty good mastering the smokey
eye has never been easier
[Music]
anytime the doctor gives you something
to bite down on before you do the
procedure it ain't going to be a fun
procedure my friend
mo freire more foreign so yeah so bucky
says he's 106. and he obviously looks
like
way younger than steve when steve's 117.
but also we know bucky's been frozen a
bunch we don't know how long he was
frozen for
like we listed everything we know but
there were probably other missions he
ran
so he's on and off but he could have
been frozen for like half of that time
right if you think about it yeah which
is true
we just don't know the just the rate at
which hydra was using this man
they're doing all this medicine to like
keep him alive and like keep him looking
fresh so
you know that's probably playing into it
but again it's tough to tell right like
how old he really is because he's he's
getting thawed and re-frozen which is
dangerous to do to your meat you can't
do that once you thought of me you can't
refreeze it folks exactly safe out there
you move your meat you lose your seed as
they say the human meat the chicken meat
whatever meat you eat
don't freeze it thaw it and then
refreeze it it's delicious
if you're gonna freeze your meat you're
gonna freeze at one time
only freeze your meat one time because
you can't do it more than once
don't freeze your meat guys hashtag
don't refreeze your meat
so he's got this knockoff erskine
formula he's aging a little differently
than steve
but it looks like it's it's working
pretty well because he's still looking
great at 106.
with an asterix oh for sure 100 he looks
great it's that all that moisturizing he
uses jergens i hear jurgens really
helps him with him just kidding no he's
it's all that frozen stuff
you know he he was definitely on ice way
more than steve was
[Music]
with steve living in his alternate
reality and not being frozen bucky is
definitely going to look a lot younger
than steve would
bucky got like the hydra version of
jergens which is just
jurgens which is just a bunch of people
named jurgens that they ground up and
made into like
a lotion because they're hydra they're
awful folks yeah
r.i.p jurgens r.i.p all you dragons
all you jurgens that were sacrificed to
make bucky barnes look so damn good
[Music]
but next we have of course uh the newest
super soldier that was introduced in
falcon and the winter soldier
isaiah bradley and we're not sure when
isaiah was born but he has to be at
least 18 to enlist in the army
so by the time he was fighting bucky in
the korean war in 1951
he was at least 18 years old but
probably closer to like 20-ish yeah they
probably weren't like pulling off
guys fresh on the line to be like give
the 18 year old some super soldier serum
you know i mean he was probably already
approved himself on the battlefield
but he was never put on ice but was
instead imprisoned
and tested on for at least 30 years 30
years that's three decades that's
insanity
but i heard that i was like are you for
real
are you for real like so sad but anyway
he probably wasn't getting good food or
decent medical care during this time
unfortunately because
you know the whole black thing but in
fact his imprisonment was probably
pretty harsh considering
his abilities because you know if you're
a strong dude you could probably break
out of prison fairly yeah they probably
had him locked up like pretty
pretty brutally and you're right like
he's not unlike
bucky who is a weapon of hydra and
they're keeping him at like peak
performance and giving him what he needs
like isaiah bradley they probably tossed
them in like a dark metal cell somewhere
kept him away from the light giving him
crappy food he's not getting to like
keep his body like in great shape
so it's just the serum doing everything
it can to hold him together plus as you
point out he's getting experimented on
so we don't know what that's doing to
him right
taking out his blood and taking dna
samples who knows what it's doing to him
yeah that man had a most likely a very
rough
time in prison and they just did not
treat this man well
um most likely because they're just
trying to figure out why the formula in
his blood works and trying to
right most likely recreate it in so
that's a lot of
prodding and uh poking and uh that's
unfun for 30 years
but he could be a lot older than we
think i mean we can
safely assume isaiah's age is at least
in the low
to mid 90s and while he shows some age
on his face it's clear
he's still pretty strong and mentally
adept as
we saw him throw that uh little uh tin
into the wall
yeah through those altoids like right
into the wall man they stuck right in
there
yeah that is 100 part of the wall now
like that
but for being at least like 90 he's in
great shape it looks tough
he looks like he could still take on
anybody he's sharp
yeah and he's pissed he's right he is
pissed
i mean i wouldn't even assume that he
owns a life alert
i don't think that he needs a life alert
life alert is a lifesaver if it weren't
for life alert i wouldn't be
sitting here today i'm not gonna talk
about it anymore
get out of my house so again this is
like he gets a knockoff erskine formula
right
the government's probably trying to
recreate it because they've lost steve
in the ice and they're not looking for
him
hard enough guys he's right there go get
him
so they come up with this new formula
they at least test it on isaiah bradley
there were probably other people they
tested on maybe it didn't work maybe it
did work who knows
but for whatever reason we can assume
that the government maybe stops trying
it for a little
while until you know big daddy ross
comes back
and starts it up again because like
there must have been a reason
they're not trying to perfect it still
maybe it was
isaiah they realized with isaiah bradley
it's like too dangerous to have these
super soldiers running around that
you've pissed off uh
and what a little agency with their life
you know what i mean
yeah i mean hopefully we find out more
about like what happened
i mean with that whole process with
isaiah as the show goes on
i mean can you imagine if you live next
to isaiah bradley
and like in that neighborhood and you're
like a kid and you keep
you know like the sandlot like you keep
knocking like balls into his backyard
and you're like
oh man i have to go into mr bradley's
backyard
last time i lost my baseball back there
he bit it in half and he spit it in my
face
he took my soccer ball and he threw it
to cleveland right
this guy's like threw it four cities
away i mean your parents are like
don't say that you can't say that about
mr bradley and you're like he's mean
he's mean i'm scared of mr bradley
yeah i would be terrified of mr bradley
because uh old people did not like me as
a child because i was uh
frankly crying all the time they don't
like you huh old people had it out for
you
i bet isaiah bradley can leave like a
full ball of halloween candy out
and like no one will take the whole bowl
you know what i mean like they'll just
take a little piece
you know you mess with mr bradley isaiah
bradley keeps a tight halloween ship
mr bradley took all my whoppers and then
he threw him into the wall
now they're stuck in the cement wall my
whoppers
i was gonna say that like he i took too
much candy through me
to another city but mr bradley threw me
anyway i don't even know what i'm saying
if you're if you're a child
that takes all the candy you deserve to
get thrown into another city
i would say so honestly i mean that's
how i don't do it that's not child abuse
that's justice
yeah cause like the candy's for
everybody because if you're taking too
much candy
other kids can't get the candy so you
live in a society
we need you to trust each other with
free candy okay exactly and isaiah's a
hero
he would never throw a child without a
good reason i trust him
i trust him to throw any child he deems
unworthy
exactly now that we got
those three main super soldiers out of
the way we got to talk about
the attempts to recreate the super
soldier's serum
in emil blonsky and of course bruce
banner now
in the mcu it's been established that
the work that bruce banner was doing
that eventually turned him into the hulk
was a part of a project
thaddeus ross was overseeing to recreate
the super soldier serum
now banner thought that gamma radiation
could replace the vita radiation
that irk sign originally used and how
that turned out for old brucey banner
uh not good he was 110 wrong
as that turned him into a giant green uh
strong booger man
though he didn't really know what he was
working he thought he was like working
on like a
radiation reducer or something weird
like a protective serum
to help people who are exposed to
radiation
they never tell the scientists what
they're really working on you know he's
dating
he's dating the boss's daughter he wants
to show off so he's like i'm going to
give myself a double dose of radiation
because i'm so good
and this is going to work so well and
some extra like
behind the glass like what is he doing
this is not what he shouldn't do this
he's actually working on super soldier
serum yeah i mean
that is a good point he was dating his
daughter so yeah
you do crazy things don't you don't date
the boss's daughter never dumb things
[Applause]
so bruce was given a recreated version
of the super soldier serum
unbeknownst to him before blasting
himself with all that gamma radiation
while his results weren't standard to
other super soldiers like for example
bruce appears to not
have any heightened abilities when he's
not the hulk we will have to see if
there are any long-term effects on his
aging because we don't really what if
bruce just like lives for like another
100 years
that'd be crazy it's true that would be
pretty nuts and i feel like that's
highly probable because and he's like
what's going on i just want to die
i i don't know anybody else bmcu that
wants to die
more than uh bruce banner unfortunately
you have to return to your body now you
don't have time i'm sorry but i'm a
ghost
but you're not dead
but his like monologue about like eating
a bullet i know so
so dark so depressing so so dark but at
the same time
bro it's hard being the hulk oh yeah
it's hard being hog hey but you got to
go to ragnarok fun
right you get to go to asgard you got to
have all those fun adventures
thank god the bullet didn't work right
seriously because he
ends up saving the universe now another
person given the super soldier serum was
of course
emil blonsky in the incredible hulk film
now
he was a special ops commando with the
british royal marines and he was born
on march 1 1971 and he was given the
super soldier serum twice
in 2010 at the age of 39 as part of
ross's efforts to capture the hulk
first he was given a small dose of the
serum and after he did that he was able
to keep up with the hulk in a fight
but was ultimately punted into a tree
trunk and
he got pretty wrecked oh my boy got
wrecked my boy got wrecked out
mega wrecked like you don't walk away
from that if you don't have serum in
your blood
yeah i feel bad too because like ross
like really talks them into taking the
ceremonies like oh you're slowing down
in your old age
seriously i'll take a little serum oh
i'm feeling great
oh look at me i'm fighting this big
green monster then boop hunted
you just can't get you know seduced by
ross it's that mustache it's so
seductive
i'm working on mine i've been working on
mine for a long time
and it ain't never coming hey man one
day and then mr blonsky ends up healing
up in a day
if you can believe it because i can't
because that's kind of insane
but he winds up getting a second bigger
dose of the serum from ross
which has some effects on his physiology
and then finally he injects himself with
bruce's gamma and
irradiated blood which turns him into
the abomination with the help of of
course
the leader um the future leader anyway
well i hope we see him again i really
have a feeling that we will but like
fingers crossed and then after being
defeated by the hulk blonsky is placed
in a cryo cell
in the vault a shield facility in barrow
alaska
and maybe he still could be there but we
don't really know what blonsky's doing
these days
so again they're putting another super
soldier on ice because potsky was like
an older guy who takes the sierra so
this will be interesting to see what
what the long-term effects of the serum
are on like old
older guys like because you're starting
at a later age maybe it doesn't work as
well does it heal up some of the aging
you already did
yeah i don't know it'll be interesting
to see but why do they have them on ice
seriously i mean they're always putting
their super soldiers on
yeah but you're just you're putting off
your problems to your children you know
what i mean
our children are gonna have to deal with
all these frozen super soldiers folks
i mean zemo had the right idea exactly
he's like there's already too many super
people around we don't need
more both bruce banner and emil blonsky
received different variations and
treatments of the original super soldier
serum
and not much time has passed for them in
order to determine what effect
if any it will have on their aging so we
can't really know for sure
but they also received it at a much
older age than steve bucky or isaiah did
so
you know we're just gonna have to see
how that plays out in the long term
maybe the effects will be different who
knows maybe the gamma doesn't help the
aging
we'll have to see i mean mark ruffalo
looks pretty good i think he has the
serum in him i think they actually did
it that was all just method acting he
was like put it in me
oh man if disney has the serum you know
they're keeping these actors alive
forever oh yeah for sure
like robert downey jr is getting the
first get the first dose
oh he's definitely coming back he's
coming back baby and of course if we're
talking super soldiers we have to talk
about
the new super soldiers on the block the
flag smashers now
we don't know how carly morgenthau and
the flax masters received their super
soldier serum
yet or what version or variation of it
that they did get but we are assuming
that the power broker
gave them the serum but we'll have to
wait and see who the power broker is
and where the supply of serum is coming
from this is our first
female recipient of the super soldier
serum that we know of
and in the real world you know
medications affect men and women very
differently this is always a big topic
like they do
a lot of clinical tests are done on men
but they're not done on women and so
carly could have totally different side
effects from it
uh maybe she'll age even less maybe
she'll benjamin button it and turn into
a baby
baby flag smashers baby flag smashers
ruining wow that's a whole disney plus
spin-off for the kids
babies black smashers we don't want we
don't want
any mayonnaise anywhere no cribs
and finally uh the last super sword that
we're gonna talk about is a super
soldier that people tend to forget
is a super soldier but red skull aka
johann schmidt oh yeah baby captain
america
captain vormir uh is more like it you
are failing me
so johan schmidt aka red skull is also a
super soldier and he injected himself
with a beta version
of the irksen formula and it had some
you know
unthrilling side effects mainly to his
facial region
yeah because erskine's telling steve
about how like the serum like enhances
whatever's inside of you and because
you know johan schmidt was full of
nothing great he was full of awful
evilness
uh it really manifested itself in a
scary-ass face
i think you meant he was full of [ __ ]
brandon he was just full of [ __ ]
and it made him angrier and made him
even more power-hungry so much so that
he was gonna
you know bite the hand that feeds him he
was ready to take out the nazis which
it's a good thing but yeah it's not good
to replace them with hydra it's it's a
thousand times worse
i say we should have let him take out
the nazis and then and then take him out
there we go that's the order of
operations i should have been a general
move over ross
i'm coming in for your job though we are
not exactly sure when red skull was born
we do know that he took the serum around
1940
and then he gets teleported away from
earth by the tesseract
in 1945 and is still alive on vormir
when thanos shows up in 2018
though it is sort of hard to tell if
that's from the serum
or the cosmic powers of the infinity
stones now that he was a guardian of the
soul stone
or you know just the power of hate which
keeps you alive
he's just kind of like floating there
right we don't like see his feet do we
i don't i don't even know if he has feet
does he have feet
yeah he's kind of like mysterious and
again once you've been
teleported to space the rules are out
the window you can live
for however long who knows how long you
live on former you're totally right
because like once you start getting
cosmic things are
like sort of out the window because he
knew everybody's like names and
backgrounds up there
right right he's getting like
information downloaded to his head so
the normal aging process is out the
window at this point one set of super
soldiers we haven't talked about we kind
of briefly mentioned them
are the ones that like in 1991 when
bucky steals
the stuff from the starks r.i.p and then
they make like five other super soldiers
and we think zemo's gonna like let him
out but he just winds up killing him
we don't know much about them other than
that they were created it doesn't appear
that they got any sort of like vita rays
or gamma radiation it was just injected
and they got all
angry and then they started rebelling
and gets their captures so hydra put
them on ice like immediately and then
they don't even get thawed out and they
just get shot
they look like the same age when they
got shot but again they've been frozen
the whole time
so it's hard to tell what effects if any
uh it had on their aging process when
they were given the serum so
we don't really need we don't have to go
too deep into them they're dead yeah
they're dead they're gone they're dead
and gone we don't really they weren't
really major characters but we have to
mention them because they were super
soldiers so
looking at all these different super
soldiers and their varying aging
abilities it seems like the serum
effects
on the body cells metabolism and
regeneration abilities
slow the natural aging process and gives
the super soldiers a much
longer life provided that they still
treat their bodies well
and avoid over-testing by fascist
political groups because that's just
not good for the body it's not good for
the body so the serum's doing some good
work but you also got to do the work
yourself
you know eat right drink plenty of water
the whole food pyramid
yeah the whole food pyramid well i think
it's on the side now i think they got
rid of the pyramid or it was like 10
pyramids i don't know
i think it's a dodecahedron now i think
it's the food doha decahedron
yeah so it sounds like empty the serum
the way it's it slows down their aging
because they're able to like regrow
their cells
that us regular humans aren't regrowing
so well
that's how they're they're staying young
fresh and agile well that was great
fantastic mt great job we're gonna dive
into our bite size questions next
but first a word from some of the folks
that help us bring you
big question we could all benefit from
unplugging every now and then
one of my favorite ways to rest my eyes
and relax is when i put on my recon
wireless earbuds and listen to some
great music or like a goofy podcast
i hate wired headphones i'm wearing them
now and it's a terrible idea because you
end up yanking them
or you know you pull them out
accidentally or sometimes when i'm like
karate chopping i catch it and just
yanks right out
sometimes it's like when i'm trying to
look cool and i just yank them out of my
ears it's awful
and i often miss like the best part of
my goofy podcast that i'm listening to
or
i miss my favorite part of the song and
then i'm fumbling around for 30 seconds
and my vibe
it's ruined it's over it's over raycons
they have no dangling wires or stems to
get in your way
they come in a range of stylish colors
but always with a comfortable and
discreet in-ear fit
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction and bluetooth
that pairs quickly and
seamlessly they have enough battery life
for six hours of playtime so the music
doesn't have to stop
until you need to charge them again the
best part raycon makes great sound
accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds starting
at half the price of other premium audio
brands
raycon's offering 15 off all their
products for our listeners and here's
what you got to do to get it
you go to buy raycon.com bigquestion
that's it by raycom.com bigquestion
you'll get 15 off your entire raikon
order so feel free to grab a pair
and a spare that's 50 off at
byraycon.com
big question by raycon.com big question
a pair and a spare don't mind if you're
in a spare
now i know a bunch of people whose
parents aren't native english speakers
and they don't speak their parents first
language
learning a new language is tough even
when your family is speaking it now
thanks to babel the number one selling
language learning app there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language
babel teaches bite size language lessons
that you'll actually
use that's what's great about babble
babble's 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way
to learn a new language on the go like
when you're driving or cleaning your
home whatever
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversations in
mind
things that you'll get to use in
everyday life because it makes sense
because why are you going to speak like
you don't speak in everyday life
captain america vote bibliotech
captain america
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective now with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish
french italian and german which is a
great language
plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation
and accent which is very nifty start
your new language learning journey today
with babble because right now when you
purchase a three month babble
subscription
you'll get an additional three months
free that's six months for the price of
three it's a great deal so just go to
babel.com
use the promo code big question that is
b a b
b e l dot com code big question all one
word no spaces for an extra three months
free
babble language for life okay mt are you
ready to dive into some bite-sized
questions
okay so our first question comes from
khaleesi stormborn
on discord and they ask who's richer
bruce wayne or tony stark there have
been several
real world publications and institutions
that have weighed in on the wealth of
famous comic book characters it's a
popular subject uh in 2020 last year i
don't know if you'll call it terrible
year
vanquish bank in the uk estimated some
superhero salaries by looking at the
average salary for their listed
profession and the city where they are
based
or like the real world equivalent of the
fictional cities that they belong to
because gotham ain't a real city what i
don't know if you know this i don't know
so for bruce wayne they came up with an
annual salary of 988
902 dollars that's a great salary that's
an amazing salary for tony stark the
annual salary they come up with was 920
0006 dollars uh i know these numbers got
a little wacky but that's because the
vanquish bank is in the uk and they did
it in pounds and we had to transfer it
over to dollars so it's not a very
smooth thing but
great salaries all around
and that's just the annual salary
assuming they're still doing their jobs
i'll save in the world
uh so batman comes out with the
advantage here but salary alone
does not constitute wealth in 2013
forbes looked at bruce and tony's
overall wealth
bruce wayne's overall wealth which
includes all of his assets businesses
owned and family inheritance was 9.2
billion the same forbes article said
tony stark's
overall wealth was 12.4 billion dollars
so this gives tony the advantage
now just for some perspective jeff bezos
is currently worth about 182 billion
dollars
which is insane it really dwarfs what we
assume are these mega
mega rich people jeff bezos makes them
look like chumps chumps
uh jeff bezos could fight crime this
whole time and chooses not to
yeah instead he's fighting unions what a
jerk
what a big old jerk captain america
captain amenity am i saying jeff bezos's
red skull i don't know you read into the
subtext
[Laughter]
so looking at where all their money
comes from both bruce and tony have like
a ton of defense contracts which can
bank some serious cash i mean that's
where the money's going
tony also has a lot of money coming from
the energy sector
as well as money he gets from stark
industries and some of their
subsidiaries
like in the comics they bought out
staying international
a company called acutec cordco they're
all under like stark industry so a very
rich company
but wayne enterprises is no slouch of a
company itself
it's one of the oldest companies in the
dc universe having started like in the
17th century the waynes have been making
money the wayne enterprise has been
around for a long time
they have a ton of subsidiaries it's
this crazy long list
in almost every industry including
aerospace botanicals pharmaceuticals
electronics
entertainment they own the daily planet
you know very bezos like owning the
newspaper
retail oil and construction those are
just a few of the subsidiaries but it's
literally like
anything you could think of they there's
like a wayne version of it
they have a lot of money you also have
to consider like family wealth here
howard stark was a self-made man who
started out with nothing
and built a very successful company in
stark industries the wanes
on the other hand are old money we're
talking
like the bedrock of gotham city old
money you know they're very similar to
some real world old money families like
the rockefellers
the rothschilds or the hearse the money
goes back over many generations and it
just like accumulated over time and just
keeps
growing that's i mean wouldn't it be
nice just to have a little
taste of it a little taste of that old
money delicious old money taste i bet it
tastes delicious
i'm like grandma where's the old money
she's like
there is no old man there is no old
money
while tony stark might be the richer man
like on paper
i think bruce wayne probably might
secretly be the richer man here okay
because you know there's some secret
money buried away in the family vault
there's a lot of assets they could sell
i bet
he's he's got the advantage over tony
here for sure oh yeah probably sorry
some swiss bank accounts that no one
knows about you know oh yeah
there's some there's some wayne money
floating around that ain't on the books
dog
oh yeah but still jeff bezos is
wealthier than both of them combined so
he's the he's the real winner here i
guess i guess not in my heart
but he is he's gonna watch this and he's
gonna cancel
all of my amazon packages he's gonna
post
everything i've ordered online he's like
listen this is what mt orders
uh he bought a body pillow to cry into
last week
um that's not true okay you don't have
to cry into a pillow no one can stop you
i ordered two
just kidding that's that's also not true
anyway okay our second bite-sized
question
wouldn't falcon's face be covered in
bugs once he's done flying around in the
sky
uh and this came from iaj smith24
also on our discord channel i i saw this
question
and i had to dive into it because it it
made me laugh so hard just thinking
about like falcon flying around getting
bugs in his face
because it's true like he probably does
catch
a few bugs on his face while he's flying
around yeah i don't know if you know
this mt i remember reading about this a
while ago and it blew my mind
but there are trillions of insects like
migrating over our heads every year
through the air
and it's like way more than anyone ever
thought like scientists
started studying this and quantifying it
by using like radar
beams to count the insects and also by
like putting nets
up at like different heights and
catching insects
to see like what number of insects they
would find at like different altitudes
and they found like
trillions of them that is insane and
scary i wish i didn't know that
and like most of them are alive too it
was like only one percent of them that
were just like dead carcasses blowing
around like most of those bugs are like
alive and they're migrating and stuff
and it's not even bugs with wings that
are up there because there are some
spiders who can make like long
strings of silk and they basically just
hold them like a kite and like fly are
you kidding me
i'm not joking that's freaking dope
that's so cool
why is there no spider kite man that'd
be amazing
yeah spider-man should just be flying
around with like long strings of web
yeah that is so cool i love that makes a
lot of sense
uh so scientists in the uk alone this is
just the united kingdom
observed over 3.37 trillion
insects migrating between 500 and 4000
feet so up in that area
which sam's spending a lot of time
flying around at that height
and they could go higher because they
found bugs way up high they found like
bees on top of mount everest
they figured out bees could fly in
atmosphere as thin as like 29 000 feet
up in the air
which is crazy so you have all these
bugs flying around up there
and if we assume so if over the uk
there's 3.37 trillion
insects we have to assume over every
landmass there's about that many insects
flying around
and scientists say there could be even
more in areas that are closer to the
equator because it's pretty cold
up in the uk when you get high up but
like closer to the equator it's pretty
warm there could be even more bugs
uh so sam's probably hit a bug or two
or a thousand while he's like flying
around
at least two bugs yeah yeah in some
cases he might be going fast enough that
like it just gets refrigerated and he
doesn't notice it like it's a little bug
but every now and then you know he's
catching like a wasp on his face he's
like ah yeah
which why didn't tony build him like a
full mask like do you think seriously
do you think tony like was like do you
want a full mask he's like no i like the
goggles i like to be able to breathe
i don't like having stuff on my face i
like to think that tony had the mask
ready and then uh sam didn't sign the
accord she was like
you don't get the money you don't get
this bug-free mask
no you criminal yeah i bet he's like
swallowed some bugs too and he's just
like too proud to talk about it
like oh yeah i mentioned that he's like
swallowing bugs up there
i did when i was researching this i read
a i read like a story and this is
apocryphal but like
a guy talking about being on his
motorcycle uh and
he ran into a june bug like hit him in
the testicle and he was going like 50
miles an hour
and he said it hurt so bad so i can't
even imagine what poor sam is getting up
there
uh up in the sky that is gonna be
covered biggest fear brandon a june bug
to the testicles
i never wish anything even my
even my biggest enemy i would never wish
a junebug to the testicles
for 50 miles an hour heck no no maybe 49
miles per hour but never 50
never 50. that's too fast well mt it's
time for the
our favorite part of the show and that's
where we get into the box subscribe
box of scraps
box of scraps these boxes beat you to
the boxes
you did it with a box of surprises in a
cave with a box of scraps
today's box of scraps question is in
falcon in the winter soldier john walker
goes back to his old high school for his
big
good morning america interview now do
you have a good memory about returning
to a school at an older age brandon well
i mean i have a memory i don't know if
it's a good memory
when i was in after i'd graduated high
school and i'm a freshman in college
uh i spent the spring semester back in
my hometown
uh and one of the jobs you could get as
a fresh-faced 18 year old boy
was taking a six hour training class and
then you're
able to be a substitute teacher right so
for whatever reason i decided to be a
substitute teacher
and i'm mostly doing like elementary
schools you know because to them
an 18 year old is a 100 year old you
know i'm an adult they respect me
but my math teacher who i really liked
in high school found out i was back in
town and i was subbing and she was like
oh i would love for you to sub
for me one day because like teachers can
request a specific sub and i was like
yeah okay
and this so i go back to my high school
less than a year out of graduating and
i'm like this is so cool i'm gonna be
the teacher
and i'm gonna see all my some of my
friends that i still have there and all
that stuff
it was a terrible experience no one
respected me
they were just goofing on me all day and
i must have looked insane
walking around like i'm a uh a teacher
now uh
and so i i could go eat in the teacher's
lounge if i wanted to but i didn't
because i was like scared to go into the
teacher's lab
well then i sat with like the kids which
is probably not a good idea either so
i've got no respect from anybody
thankfully i only subbed for her for one
day uh and thankfully i gave up my
teaching career because i don't think i
was bored to be a teacher
but never go back and sub your high
school like less than a year out of
leaving it because it's not
a bad experience that sounds really
interesting
yeah i feel like that you're being your
age at that time is a very
really awkward thing to be a substitute
yeah oh man
well for me i think that the only thing
i could really think of
was you know somewhat recently when i
went back to my old college
because i graduated in 2014 and i was
like you know what a couple years
later i was like i'm gonna go back see
what things what's going on there
um and it was very weird um seeing all
the new freshmen
because they all look like babies
brandon they all look like baby children
and it was at that point that i realized
time
was doing cruel things to me and making
me older and making the kids younger
you're aging you can't help it exactly
it's all that aging that i
i strongly urge our viewers to stop just
stop
doing it it's not it's unfun but yeah if
that that that was the time when i
realized wow i'm
actually an adult because these 18 year
olds look like i don't know
12 year olds so like now i guess it's
time
for me to join aarp or something i don't
know
that's that's when you know you're an
adult mtv when you start looking at
at children and being like they're too
young to eat their children whenever i
see like young
like i don't know like middle schoolers
like holding hands in relationships i'm
like what do you know about
love what do you know i was there when
love was invented
the ghost of christmas future coming in
being like beware
right yeah this is your destiny
don't do it don't do it
don't date anyone under 20. like just
don't date until you're like 21.
yourself not worth it yeah yeah if
you're if you're in middle school and
you're listening to this
break up break up it's not going to work
out i'm sorry to be the bearer of bad
news but just break it off just break up
just focus on school i don't know color
color a thing i don't know what people
do in middle school learn your
division color or something and just i'm
chill i'm pretty sure middle school is
coloring and division
you nailed it yes coloring division and
then and then high school they teach you
how to color in the lines which is yeah
right
that's true that's what it's about being
adult learning to color in the lines oh
boy
well this has been a depressing episode
of big question
but thank you so much for joining me on
this episode uh
you can follow mtn mastertainment follow
me at grin and barrack figure out how to
spell it
uh follow new rock stars send us your
big questions and use the hashtag big
question
if you're listening to the podcast
subscribe to the feed and give us a nice
reading and review
and make sure you subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube and hit that
notification bell
uh this has been a blast mt i can't wait
to do it with you again sometime
hey you're the man brandon you always
know you're the man i'm always telling
you the man you're the man brandon oh
you're the man
um actually you're the man brandon don't
i already
will be the man yes thank you geez thank
you
thanks everybody bye
[Music]
you